Bitte schön.
Ja, hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin heute auf der Notfallaufnahme in dieser Klinik als
Asst.
Bevor ich Sie körperlich untersuche, möchte ich einfach allgemeine
Frage über Ihre Person und Beschwerde stellen.
Deswegen möchte ich mit Ihnen eine Messgeschichte oder
Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit auch einbestanden?
Ja, guten Abend erst mal Herr Doktor.
Sie fragen mich doch gar nicht, was ich habe.
Sie wollen gleich nach meiner Person fragen.
Ich komme her, weil ich Beschwerden habe.
Hallo.
Ja, wir können wieder starten.
Ja, gerne.
Deswegen bin ich ja da.
Hallo, wie heißen Sie hier nochmal?
Okay, wie heißen Sie?
Ja, wie heißen Sie denn Herr Doktor?
Wie ist Ihr Name?
Usta ist mein Name.
Usta, okay.
Guten Abend Herr Doktor Usta.
Ja, Usta ist mein Name.
Mein Name ist Katharina Seba.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachname Buchstabieren?
Mein Nachname ist Seba, das ist Siegfried Emil.
Emil Bertha, Emil Richard.
Seba, ja, Frau Seba.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 78 Jahre alt.
Mein Geburtstatum ist der 12. Februar, 1900.
Was ist das? 45?
45.
Ja, ich glaube, 45, ja.
Okay.
Wie schwer sind Sie und wie viel größen Sie?
Wie groß ich bin.
Ja, groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 82 kg.
Ja, 82.
Ich bin etwas kleiner geworden, 1 Meter 69 glaube ich.
69.
Ja, 30 Meter.
Was wird Sie zu uns?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich merke, dass mein Rechte ein dicker ist
als das linke Bein.
Und ich habe so eine Spannung auf dem Bein und ein bisschen weh.
Ja, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ungefähr seit 2, 3 Tagen nimmt das zu.
Ja.
Und deswegen bin ich da, weil ich mir jetzt Sorgen mache.
Wie beschreiben Sie diese dicker Beine
und alles, alles, die anderen Beine dicken?
Ja, also mein rechtes Bein, Sie sehen ja, wenn Sie anschauen,
das ist vom Umfang her deutlich dicker als das linke Bein.
Ja.
Und haben Sie die gleiche Beschwerde früher gehabt?
Nein.
Nein, also ich habe schon eine Knieartrose,
schon seit längerem.
Und da war das Knie schon etwas angeschwollen,
das weiß ich, das habe ich schon länger.
Aber diese Art von Schmerzen hatte ich bisher noch nicht.
Ja, diese Schmerzen schmerzen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinauf
oder nur Waden und Unterschenkel?
Nein, das ist das ganze Bein.
Also ich habe Schmerzen an der Ohren und Unterschenkel,
aber auch am Oberschenkel habe ich Schmerzen.
Das spannt so ein bisschen.
Ja, wo die Schmerzen genau sind
und als Knie oder Unterschenkelwaden
oder auf Oberschenkel?
Kann ich schwer sagen, Herr Doktor, deswegen bin ich da.
Also meine Wade tut ein bisschen weh.
Wie gesagt, die Schmerzen habe ich schon immer gehabt.
Aber auch mein Oberschenkel, das ist deutlich größer geworden
und das spannt so und das tut auch weh.
Ja, füllen Sie sich Hitze oder über Temperatur auf der Knie?
Nein, Wärme fülle ich da jetzt nicht.
Sind linke Beine röter als die andere?
Nein, nein, also Farbunterschied habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und haben sich die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit verschlechtert?
Ja, also das wird jetzt zudem stärker, die Schmerzen.
Ja, und gibt es Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Das weiß ich nicht, deswegen bin ich ja da bei Ihnen, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß ja gar nicht, was es ist.
Was kann du von jetzt auf nach?
Zum Beispiel beim Gehen oder beim Treppenscheigen füllen Sie sich die Schmerzen?
Ja klar, ich bin beim Laufen eingeschränkt, also durch die Schmerzen kann ich auch schlechter laufen, das stimmt ja.
Ja, wenn Sie gehen oder laufen, füllen bekommen Sie Luftmord oder Atemmord?
Ja, kann man schon sagen, ich bin schon seit einiger Zeit etwas schwer mit der Luft.
Wie gesagt, das Laufen ist eingeschränkt, ich kann nicht schnell laufen.
Ich hatte vor vier Wochen ungefähr eine Operation und seitdem ist das mit dem Laufen und mit der Luft auch etwas schwieriger.
Ich verstehe nicht, welche Operationen haben Sie?
Ich habe einen Blasenkrebs, ein Hahnblasenkrebs gehabt und da hat man mir die Blase operiert.
Geile Blasen oder?
Hahnblase.
Also die Frauen meinten, das ist ein Urotelca oder so ähnlich.
Ich kenne sie, ich kenne sie ja nicht aus und die mussten meine Blase entfernen.
Was meintest du mit ein Blasenkrebs?
Blasenkrebs.
Blasen, ja, Blasen, okay.
Kann ich mir nicht verstehen, ist das schlecht?
Ja, ich glaube, die Ärzte machen Operationen
und ich glaube, sind sie wieder gesund?
Ich habe Ihre Frage jetzt nicht verstanden, Herr Doktor, was meinen Sie?
Ich glaube, die Ärzte, sie wurden operiert und damit sie wieder gesund werden
und ich glaube, ja, das passiert.
Ich glaube, die Urotelca, ich glaube.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was Sie jetzt genau meinen, Herr Doktor, aber man hat die Diagnose festgestellt.
Ich habe einen Blasenkrebs und die Ärzte haben gesagt, dass sie operiert werden
und deswegen habe ich eine Operation bekommen.
Haben Sie, gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen blinden oder verstärkt?
Ja, wie Sie schon sagten, wenn ich versuche zu laufen, dann werden die Schmerzen schlimmer.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie eine lange Reise gemacht in letzter Zeit?
Nein, ich war ja im Krankenhaus, wie sollte ich da eine Reise machen?
Also nach der Operation war ich ungefähr 10 Tage im Krankenhaus
und ich soll ab nächster Woche in eine Reha gehen, in eine Kur.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Schüttefrost?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie kalten Schweiß bemerkt?
Nein, das auch nicht.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Ebrechen?
Nein, auch das habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Und nach der Operation, blase Operation, haben Sie Verstopfung oder Durchfall?
Ja, nach der Operation hatte ich ein bisschen Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang.
Also ich hatte tagelang keinen Stuhlgang, ein bisschen Verstopfung.
Aber jetzt geht es wieder ganz gut.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Pusten?
Pusten habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich Schwindel gefühlt oder?
Ob ich Schwindel habe?
Ja, Schwindel.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie bestimmte Allergien?
Ja, einige Medikamente vertrage ich nicht.
Da hatte ich in der Vorgeschichte ein bisschen Probleme.
Ich bin, jetzt muss ich überlegen, gegen Penicillin und noch ein anderes Antibiotikum.
Da weiß ich den Namen nicht mehr, bin ich allergisch.
Und wenn ich Schmerzmedikamente nehme wie Novalgin, dann bekomme ich auch so einen Hautausschlag.
Ja, Novalgin.
Ja, und gibt es bestimmte Medikamente, die in dieser Letztzeit nehmen?
Ja, ich habe noch einige andere.
Ich habe ja noch einen Blutdruck, ich habe ja Diabetes.
Und dagegen nehme ich auch einige Medikamente.
Wie sind Sie, welche Medikamente, die Sie nehmen?
Da muss ich meine Liste mal schauen, einen Moment.
Also hier ist meine Medikamentenliste, da habe ich zum einen Ramipril, 5 Milligramm.
Ja, Ramipril, 5 Milligramm.
Dann nehme ich morgens und abends.
Ja.
Ramlodipin, 10 Milligramm, morgens eine Tablette.
Nur morgens?
Nur morgen.
Dann habe ich hier Metaprolol 95, halbe morgens, eine halbe abends.
Hier steht noch Metformin, 850, eine morgens, eine abends.
Lieben die Eltern noch?
Nein, ich kann das nicht sagen.
Ja.
Und wenn die Eltern gestorben sind, woran die Eltern gestorben?
Also woher sind meine Eltern gestorben?
Ja, gestorben sind, ja.
Meine Mutter hatte Brustkrebs.
Ja.
Und mein Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Und wann sind die Eltern gestorben?
Also meine Mutter vor ungefähr 10 Jahren.
Ja, vor 10 Jahren.
Und meine Vater starb vor 2 Jahren.
Das ist doch früher.
Ja gut, da war auch schon fast 80 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin alleine.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe 2 Kinder, eine Tochter und ein Sohn.
Ja, sind Sie gesund?
Ja, glücklicherweise haben die Kinder bisher nichts.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Kinder?
Nein, du, Sie.
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich lebe mit meinem Ehemann zusammen.
Ja, okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Rentnerin, mit 78 Jahren.
Wie ist die Appetit?
Ja, in letzter Zeit etwas schlecht.
Ich habe keine großen Hunger nach der Operation.
Ja, und haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ich hatte vor der Operation zu circa 10 kg abgenommen.
Aber nach der Operation nicht mehr weiter.
Insgesamt bin ich jetzt 10 kg weniger als vor 2 Monaten.
Ja, gab es in der Vergangenheit?
Keine Operationen?
Nein.
Ich hatte nur einen Arzt meinte, das ist eine Arthrose.
Solange es geht, machen wir keine Operationen.
Und wenn die Schmerzen zunehmen,
werden wir operieren, aber bisher habe ich noch keine Operation.
Ich will auch keine Operationen, Doktor.
Ja, und gab es in der Vergangenheit bestimmte Vorerkrankungen?
Außer Blutdruck und Schockkrankheit?
Nein, ich war relativ fit.
Und nur Blasenzimmer?
Ja, leider.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen nach der Operation?
Ja, natürlich. Ich kann ja nicht normal Wasserlassen.
Ich habe einen künstlichen Ausgang bekommen, einen Beutel.
Sie sehen hier.
Ein Schlauch ist jetzt angeschlossen.
Und der Urin läuft in den Beutel.
Ich kann nicht normal Wasserlassen.
Wie ist das Wasserlassen von der Farbe?
Rot oder nur Geld?
Ich meine den Urin.
Die Urin ist eigentlich relativ hell und klar.
Es ist gelb immer.
Doktor, Sie fragen mich schon so viele Fragen.
Ist das etwas Schlimmes, was ich habe, Doktor?
Ich glaube nicht Schlimmes.
Ich glaube nur wegen der Operation haben Sie eine Hautentzündung.
Ich glaube.
Deswegen kann ich Ihnen sagen, das ist nicht schlimm.
Aber das ist jetzt zu entscheiden.
Sie wollen doch sicherlich mich noch untersuchen und Blut abnehmen.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich würde gerne einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Okay.
Ja, wird mich freuen. Deswegen bin ich hier.
Ja, okay.
Angst, ob das etwas Schlimmes ist oder nicht.
Wie sind Sie, wenn man eine Krebsdiagnose hat,
dann denkt man immer, da kommt immer noch etwas Schlimmes.
Ja, möchtet ihr etwas hinzufügen,
weil ich alle meine Fragen gestellt habe?
Nein, ich bin dankbar, wenn Sie mich untersuchen
und mir danach sagen können, ob das etwas Schlimmes ist
oder was ich noch tun kann.
Ja, ich habe vergessen.
Brauchen Sie?
Entschuldigung, brauchen Sie?
Nein, ich brauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu schon.
Zum Essen und so weiter trinke ich schon ein bisschen Wein.
Ja, und wie viel Croboch oder Protac?
Wie viel Glas?
Abends zum Gläschen Wein zum Essen.
Das gönne ich mir noch.
Ja, okay.
Und nehmen Sie bitte persönlich, das ist eine allgemeine Frage,
die ich jedem Patientem stellen muss.
Haben Sie mit Kontakt drogen?
Mit roben? Nein, nein, nein.
Ja, mit rogen.
Nein.
Danke schön für alle Informationen.
Und dann sehen wir uns nach der Zeit,
nach der Untersuchung.
Okay, okay.
Was haben Sie Blut abgenommen, Herr Doktor?
Welche Laborwerte wollen Sie untersuchen?
Ich würde vorab klären, würde ich folgende Untersuchung
durchführen, Blutbild und ZPR.
Was ist ZPR?
Zereaktives Protein, das ist eine Entzündungsparameter.
Und ZRP, nicht ZPR.
Okay, was noch?
Und BSEG.
BSEG, ja, die Blutspunk.
Ja, BSEG und Leberwerte.
Leberwerte, ja.
Leberwerte und Nierenwerte.
Okay.
Und, was noch?
Wollen Sie die Sauerstoffsettingen messen?
Ja.
Blutgase?
Ja, Blutgase und...
Dedimere?
Ja, Dedimere, ja.
Okay, was machen Sie noch?
Ein EKG.
Ja, ich schreibe ein EKG.
Okay, was machen Sie noch für eine Untersuchung?
Ich untersuche mit Publikationografie.
Und ob die Durchblutung...
Durchblutungstörung...
ist oder nicht?
Okay, welche Gebete?
Schauen Sie die Arterien oder die Wien?
Ich glaube, die Wien.
Nein, ich...
Arterien.
Weil die Spannung oder die Beine
ist nicht rot.
Das ist hell.
Deswegen.
Okay, also Sie schauen die Arterien
ob die Patientin Durchblutungstörmen hat.
Ja, ich mache die Wien.
Beide.
Warum? Was wollen Sie in den Wien anschauen?
Weil die Patientin...
Bei der Patientin gab es
eine schwere Operation.
Nein, die Beine hatten keine Operation.
Okay, machen wir nachher.
Okay, dann fragen Sie die Kollegen
und andere Fragen.
Oder haben die Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wie bitte? Eine?
Ich habe 6 Sitzungen
Chemotherapie vor der Operation bekommen
und soll auch später nach der Reha
noch mal eine Chemotherapie bekommen.
Ja, wann war der Rest der Chemotherapie?
Das war vor der Operation.
Was war die Operation?
Wurden Sie nur handraßen entfert
oder auf der Knote?
Die haben zu mir gesagt, die ganze Handblase muss raus.
Dann haben sie die ganze Handblase operiert.
Ich glaube, die haben auch noch einige andere Sachen
mitoperiert, aber da muss ich in den Arztbrief gucken.
Okay, nach der Operation haben Sie
Gerinnungshema eingenommen?
Was sind Gerinnungshema?
Also Blutverdünnende Medikamente?
Ich habe Bauchspritzen gehabt bis vor 2 Wochen.
Da haben Sie hartig Bauchspritzen, die habe ich aber nicht mehr.
Okay.
Das war meine Frage.
Danke schön. Andere Fragen?
Ich habe die Chemotherapie getestet.
Ich habe die Schmerzen getestet.
Die Schmerzen werden seit 3 Tagen schlimmer.
Ja.
Zuerst waren sie beim Laufen schmerzhaft.
Aber heute wird es auch in Ruhe.
Schmerzhaft, so dass ich deswegen hier gekommen bin.
Und die Schwellung nimmt die Schmerz nicht mehr.
Ich habe die Schmerzen getestet.
Also bei einer Skala, von 1 bis 10, würde ich sagen jetzt bei 4 bis 5.
Okay, ich glaube, wir machen jetzt eine Übergabe.
Dann können wir besprechen, was es ist.
Hello, meine Kollegen.
Hallo, meine Kollegen.
mich? Herr Oberarzt. Herr Oberarzt. Hallo Herr Oberarzt, Hallo Herr Uster, Sie sind doch
der neue Assistent. Ja. Herzlich willkommen, gut. Man hat sich sehr viel von Ihnen erzählt, dass
Sie ein sehr eifriger Arzt sind, aber ich hatte Sie noch nicht gesehen. Guten Tag, freut mich sehr.
Ja, bitte schön. Guten Tag. Jetzt Katharina Seber, die ich…
Ich möchte eine… Entschuldigung, wenn ich es so unterbreche. Sie möchten einen Patienten
vorstellen oder? Ja, ich möchte eine Patientin vorstellen.
Ah, okay, ja. Die Sie aufgenommen haben oder was ist mit der Patientin?
Ja, ich habe in der Notaufnahme gesehen. Okay, dann bitte schön. Ja, dann verstehe ich
jetzt, was Sie möchten. Katharina Seber ist 78 Jahre alt.
78? 78 Jahre alt und 1,69 Meter und 82 Kilogramm.
1,69 Meter groß? Groß und 82 Kilogramm.
Schwer. Schwer. Okay.
Sie hat sich wegen zunehmenden Schmerzen und Schwellung…
Ja, Schwellung im…
… war das nicht das erste Bein, aber egal, vorgestellt, ja.
Im linken Bein vorgestellt hat.
Nicht vorgestellt, hat sich vorgestellt, genau.
Ja. Und Frau Seber klagte über…
Über Schmerzen wahrscheinlich, haben Sie doch gesagt.
Ja, ja, über Schmerzen und die Fragen, Übelkeit, Erbrechen und Fieber wurden verneinert.
Und die Patienten, bei den Patienten gab es in ihrer Vergangenheit,
die Urät-ZEA und sie wurden wegen Urät-ZEA operiert.
Wann war die Operation?
Vor zehn Tagen.
Vor zehn Tagen? Ja.
Vor vier Wochen.
Vor zehn Tagen ist sie entlassen worden aus dem Krankenhaus.
Ja, ja, okay.
Und die Gewichtsveränderung ist vor der Operation…
Die Patientin hat vor der Operation 10 Kilogramm abgenommen.
Ja, okay.
Ja, und die Patientin hat Blutdruck und Diabetes-Melitus.
Also sie hat als Vorerkrankungen einen Hypertonus und einen Diabetes-Melitus.
Okay.
Ja, okay.
Die Patientin nimmt für Diabetes-Melitus Metformin, 850 mg, eine morgens und eine abends.
Sehr gut.
Und bei der Patientin, bei Familien an einem Nase gab es sich folgende Informationen.
Der Vater ist vor zwei Jahren an Myokatinphaktus verstorben.
Okay.
Und die Mutter ist vor zehn Jahren an Brustkrebs verstorben.
Sie hat keine Geschwister und sie ist verheiratet.
Und sie haben zwei Kinder, eine Tochter und einen Sohn.
Und sie wohnen mit ihren Ehren.
Okay.
Und mein Verdachtdiagnose ist, wenn Trombose, es könnte wenn Trombose sein.
Sie gehen von einer tiefen Beinwähnen-Trombose aus.
Okay.
Trombose sein.
Und Alternativ kommen, Hauptentzündung, zum Beispiel die RZP, oder Phlebitis in Betracht.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne folgende Untersuchung durchführen.
Ich weiß.
Und Autohaut, Autolinken, Beinhaut würde ich gerne Publiksonografie durchführen.
Nicht auf der Haut, sondern an Bein, sagt man dann.
Ja, am Bein.
Am linken Bein.
Ja, am linken Bein.
Und ich nehme der Patientin Blutab und die Entzündungsparameter.
Okay.
Und Blutbild und Leberwerte und Nierenwerte.
Und ich schreibe natürlich ein EKG.
Okay.
Gut.
Das war es?
Ja.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Kollegen, Kollegen, etwas zu ergänzen.
Eine Frage, eine Kritik.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Was für weitere Differenzialdiagnosen,
woran denken Sie noch außer der tiefen Beinwähntrombose, RZP?
Das Bein ist geschwollen, haben Sie gesagt.
Nach einer Operation vorhin war ein kleiner Tipp da.
Was kann die Operation passieren?
Am Bein.
Ödem, oder?
Ein Lymphödem, ja.
Ja, Lymphödem.
Genau.
Und was noch?
Das reicht erst mal.
Okay.
Also, das ist richtig.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr groß,
dass diese Patientin eine tiefe Beinwähntrombose hat.
Und deswegen eine relativ schnelle Zunahme des Beinumfangs,
eine Schwellung bekommen hat.
Und der Grund ist, oder der Auslöser für diese Trombose ist
wahrscheinlich die Operation.
Ja.
Und zumal eine große Operation, sie ist lange gelegen
und hatte Bauchspritzen, also niedermilklarer Separien,
wie Klexane, hatte sie noch gehabt nach der Operation,
aber hat dann aufgehört.
Somit ist der Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr groß,
dass wir hier eine Beinwähntrombose haben.
Das können Sie mit erhöhten Dedimieren,
mit Duplexsonografie und der Unterscheid der Wähnen,
nicht der Arterien, die Wähnen anschauen.
An der Leiste, an der Kniegelenk, da kann man die Wähnen sehen,
ob sie kollabieren oder ob sie offen sind.
Wenn eine Trombose da ist, dann kann die Wähnen nicht kollabieren,
sondern die bleibt offen.
Okay?
Ja.
Wunderbar.
Was sieht man dann im EKG, wenn die Trombose schon fortgeschritten ist
und auch auf der Lunge ein Problem ausgelöst hat?
Empoli.
Eine Lungenembolie kann schon beginnen, das ist richtig.
Die Patientin hat ja auch gesagt, sie hat etwas Luftnot,
wenn sie sich belastet.
Was sieht man dann im EKG vielleicht?
Welche Veränderung bei Lungenembolie?
Ja, vergessen.
Was sagen der anderen Kollegen, der andere Ärztin,
die gute Frage gestellt hat.
Welche Veränderungen sieht man bei einer Lungenembolie?
Die Glaube, die Glaube, die Klage.
Nein.
Nein?
Was haben wir? Die können die Kollegen helfen?
Keine, ich denke.
Bei Lungenembolie.
Rechtchenkelblock?
Nein.
Rechtchenkelblock gibt es auch, aber 2, 3 und alle 11.
Also es muss nicht, aber es kann auch ein Rechtchenkelblock.
Wenn wir einen neuen Rechtchenkelblock sehen,
dann kann natürlich der Hinweis für eine Lungenembolie da sein.
Okay.
Der Kollege war sehr aufgeregt.
S1, 2, 3.
3, 3, 3, 3, 3.
Aber Rechtchenkelblock ist das woran man, glaube ich, als er erstes denkt.
Sehr gut.
Der Freund war sehr gut, aber etwas aufgeregt.
An der Grammatik müssen wir noch ein bisschen üben.
Aber mit ein bisschen Übung wird es sicherlich besser.
Was ist die Prüfung, Herr Usta?
8.
Okay, da ist noch genau 2 Monate.
War gut, aber du musst ein bisschen viel reden, Deutsch reden.
Ich glaube, du kannst diese Anämnese stief örtieren.
Ausführlich schreiben.
Ich soll schreiben?
Ja.
Die Anämnese?
Schreiben, nicht schreiben, beschreiben.
Beschreiben?
Ja, beschreiben.
Okay, also sozusagen Arztübergabe, oder?
Okay, kann ich kurz machen?
Ja.
Ich kann sagen, guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine Patientin vorstellen.
Und nicht gleich los.
Ich habe in der Notaufnahme eine Patientin angesehen oder aufgenommen.
Es ist eine Frau Seber, 78 Jahre alt.
Sie kommt mit zunehmenden Schmerzen und Schwellungen am rechten Bein,
seit 2 bis 3 Tagen.
Sie hat Schwierigkeiten beim Laufen
und gibt auch eine leichte Belastungsdyspnö an.
Das Bein ist geschwollend von der Wade und auch am Oberschenkel.
Es hat keine Farbveränderung.
Es ist aber druckschmerzempfindlich an der Wade, wenn man diese anfasst.
Die Patientin hat vor ca. 4 Wochen eine Armblasenoperation,
eine radikale Zystektomie gehabt,
mit Entfernung der Lymphknoten
und ist vor ca. 10 Tagen aus dem Krankenhaus entlassen worden.
An Vorerkrankungen sind bei ihr bekannt ein Hypertonus
und ein Diabetes Militus, welches medikamentös gut eingestellt ist.
Sie nimmt Darmepril, Amnodipin, Metoprolol und Metformin.
Weitere Medikamente hat sie nicht.
An Allergien sind bekannt eine Penicillinallergie
und eine weitere auf andere Antibiotika,
was die Patientin sagen konnte.
Zudem hat sie eine Allergie auf der Schmerzmedikament Novalgien.
Die Patientin hatte vor der Operation eine Neoatiovanthekemotherapie
und nach der Reha-Maßnahme, was sie jetzt nächste Woche antreten wird,
sind noch weitere Chemotherapien geplant.
Familienanamnestisch ist es so,
dass ihr Vater an Herzinfarkt vor 2 Jahren verstorben ist.
Die Mutter an Brustkrebs vor ca. 10 Jahren.
Die Patientin hat keine Geschwister, aber 2 Kinder.
Ein Sohn und ein Tochter, die sind gesund.
Sie lebt mit ihrem Ehemann zusammen.
Dem Ehemann geht es gut.
Das wäre ungefähr so meine Diagnosevorstellung.